[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like Brandon Shaw if you ain't
thick please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is popping
Monday morning
that's more combat
Mortal Kombat if you're not caught up on
uh The Last of Us there's a great Mortal
Kombat reference in there
you watch last night's episode a lot of
people were complaining oh it's boring
oh my God sorry there's not monsters
every episode
it was the same people like ah I need
more Marvel movies the whales sucked
where's the superheroes it's like God
damn it what's wrong with Society the
whale's good man
the oil's good
um what's popping fam it is Monday
morning February 27th man February is
flying fast huh
yeah this year's flying fast it is isn't
it yeah it's already almost marked it's
basically March Sushi March 10. it's my
birthday month and yours same day yeah
wow look at us dude
38. dude I'll be big 40.
though 40 is the new 20. yeah I'm so
young
so young dude it's like that will
Burkhart who's always he was with me and
uh
he was with me in Bakersfield and he's
with us at the Ice House ice house just
reopened they've been open six days when
I played there uh they're back with
vengeance Burkhart he's with me so funny
dude but I think he I don't know he's
like 24. posted page I took a picture
I'm like dude just two Young Bucks
trying to make it in this game look at
we're so young I just take them like
every time I tell them like dude we're
so young this is crazy dude he doesn't
really play the game he's like yeah dude
we're so young like all right well
you know I'm 40 right yeah he's so young
he looks he's crushing them it's so
[__] funny really really good dude
Hub I think he's with me and Brad too
yeah he's scratching it really you dude
I'm in Brea this Friday Friday March 3rd
Brea California the bray improv March
3rd two shows one night only uh be
meeting some special guest and the
reason why I had to cancel the other
shows is because Saturday March 4th you
think I would want to be anywhere else
besides thick boy Studios doing a
Calabasas fight campaign for Jon Jones
return I had to it's rare I canceled
dates I never do I I had to it's Jon
Jones it's the goat the best to ever do
it is back at heavyweight it's going
down this Saturday I just had to
reschedule those two shows in brand your
boy had to do it prayer sorry you guys
if you want tickets see me Friday night
but Saturday I had to do what I was born
to do and that's talk trash to my
friends I'm watching drink whiskey with
nicotine in my mouth with Jen Casey and
George and so a few special guests we
have a great lineup for the companion
now back to back companions a lot of
work for your boy yesterday's was four
hours four hours thank God for the
talent on the show four hours for Tommy
Fury Jake Paul which we'll get into but
uh hold that note because this Saturday
we have another special cow bath fight
campaign for UC 285 Jon Jones Sarah gone
you got the one the only the biggest man
no pun necessary there the biggest man
in country music period it is jelly roll
jelly roll is in studio and then you
also have the great the freaking MVP of
fight companions Rampage Jackson then we
got a very special guest he's flew all
the way from Nashville Tennessee he's on
a popular podcast called busting with
the boy days and he is blown up right
now I think he's a free agent as far as
the NFL goes play for the Raiders
Washington the Titans he's bouncing all
over but he's my brother from a more
athletic mother it is Will Compton from
busting with the boys so that is your
lineup Rampage Jackson Jerry roll and
Will Compton that's gonna be a fun one
for Jon Jones return son
busting with the boys busting nuts in
our pants right
hell yeah so um let's get right into the
fights man
oh so you had the companion uh Cowboys
fight man you can watch it right now
it's available right now on thick boy
YouTube uh Tommy Fury Jake Paul
man this is what's wrong with boxing the
timing and the production is so slow and
it's so unorganized the commentating was
awful that's why you guys tuned into us
but just everything was so slow so
delayed it was just not well done I
think the overall from top to bottom was
over five hours which is just too long
for anything for anything I mean the
Super Bowl's not the goddamn one the
Super Bowl the World Cup's not that long
but Jake Paul Tommy fear you make me
wait five hours so you know it is what
it is next time we do one of these
especially when it comes to box and
we'll probably start when they say you
know bank card starts let's say for
example 7 P.M we probably won't start
till 8 30 now do at least a 90 minute
delay because boxing just doesn't have
their [__] together how they haven't
took any lessons from how the UFC
production does it is insane like that's
why you see overtook everything because
they they're well-oiled machine you know
how things are going to go man boom boom
boom the Clockwork these guys I'm like
going to Jake Paul's locker room he's
still putting on this freaking walk out
gear you know but so let's get to the
fight
I predicted last week if you watch the
show Jake Paul under four rounds
um listen whenever you're predicting uh
two Young Bucks like a Tommy Fury who
has eight fights Jake Paul who has seven
fights now I guess Tommy has nine and
Jake has seven now do you
can't really guarantee anything I would
it would be tough to bet on this fight
so I think you saw Drake put like 700
Grand on Jake Paul obviously that's just
a promotional thing but if you were
getting he didn't definitely didn't do
that that's all fake figured out
everybody
um but if you were gonna these things
are tough to bet on because Tommy fear
and Jake Paul we don't know the
evolution of their game where they're
gonna be at they're advancing so fast
and they're learning so fast on the Fly
and they're working the tails off so
it's hard to predict the fight right
it's hard to predict the fight of that
caliber because it's not a Manny
Pacquiao Floyd Mayweather these guys who
include their hamstrers have over 100
fights or you know it's not a a Jon
Jones Alexander gustavin something like
that or uh or Tyson Fury Anthony Joshua
who have extensive amateur backgrounds
and you know in the pros we've seen them
fight over 20 times you're talking about
these guys who their first fights
they're not fighting the best caliber
Fighters so obviously there's huge holes
in their games but you don't know how
much they're training how much they're
going to advance
and by any degree of uh if you're a
trained boxing eye and you watch Tommy
Fury's previous fights it would be hard
to predict that Tommy Fury even though
he's a of the first Boxer Jake Paul
fought it'd be hard to predict that
Tommy Fury was going to fight to that
caliber it'd be hard to predict that he
was that talented that well-rounded and
could actually dismantle Jake Paul based
off his previous fights his last fight
he looked you know in Ryan Garcia said
himself you know and Ryan was so to me
the MVP of the companion I mean he's a
young kid it's the first time doing
campaign it's four hours he didn't even
eat he was intermittent fasting I think
he's gonna pass out he's great his
knowledge obviously he's a monster when
it comes to boxing just he fit right in
wasn't trying to you know step on
people's jokes and didn't interrupt and
just brilliant box in mind just a good
solid kid man such a good person shout
to Ryan Garcia it was a huge fight
coming up against tank Davis but you
know as he was saying
you know looking at Tommy's last fight
and even the fight previous to that man
you were like oh man this is gonna be a
nightmare for Tommy Fury and he just
didn't show the Improvement that Jake
did from fight to fight
so what are you gonna do you know you
got two Young Bucks going in there and
going into the fight Howie and I both
sat on companion like loser gets it gets
their pink slip losers out loser has to
leave box and if Tommy knocked out Jake
Jake has to leave if Jake knocks out
Tommy Tommy has to leave
that's not the case here I think uh I
would like to see a rematch uh I agree
with the scorecards
um
you know I and I'm biased for sure I
don't know Tommy any facet his brother's
my favorite fighter in any combat sport
I absolutely love Tyson Fury but I'm not
biased when it comes to you know the
family I don't you know it's whatever
but I love his brother
um for Jake Jake is a buddy dude no Jake
and Logan so completely biased there 100
and I think Jake trains his ass off I
get why he gets the hate and but you
know also it's a little too much but I
that being said take my biased opinion
out of this
and I was in that drunk like looking at
I was like you might give Jake two
rounds looking back on it when he had
that knock down that was for sure his
round outside that you might be able to
find him another maybe being generous
even three
you know they took a point from took a
point from uh Tommy too that ref should
never work in major boxing fight again
hey ref it ain't about you that rap you
don't have to fight it was like make
sure you like subscribe to my page like
what the hell is going on here like make
sure you get that skinny tea y'all promo
code dumbest ref in the game let's take
a little break from all this chat of the
goat Jon Jones coming back Braya see you
this Friday two shows one night in Brea
California that's Brea Improv this
freaking Friday March 3rd now I'm in
Oklahoma City March 9th through the 11th
Tacoma Washington March 23rd through the
25th get your tickets at thickboy.com
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by my friends at DraftKings after
three years away from the Octagon the
pound-for-pound goat Jon Jones Bones is
back UFC 285 is here and get in on his
title bout against Cyril gone and all
the action on the fight card with
draftking Sportsbook the official sport
it's betting part of the UFC new
customers can bet just five dollars on
the pre-fight money line and get 150
dollars in bonus bets if your fighter
wins all DraftKings customers can join
the excitement in the octagon with
DraftKings same game parlays combine
multiple UFC 285 bets and do one for a
shot at even bigger payout listen man
there's some fun favorites on here I
would bet all my money on Beau nickel to
get the job done via finish your Friday
night's game right Jaylen Turner might
want to stay away from that one uh
chefchenko Alexa Grosso I think Chef
Chang has something to prove she's also
a favorite but you could parlay Jon
Jones chefchenko uh shaft cat and Bo
nickel and make some Bank bro do it
download the app use code shop show
schab show new customers combat just
five dollars on a pre-fight money line
and get one hundred and fifty dollars in
bonus bets if your fighter wins this
Saturday at draftking Sportsbook with
the code shop show schab show minimum
age eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details DraftKings get
your draft on
listen up here Fellers and ladies I only
recommend products that I actually use
on a daily basis whether it's on its
supplements whatever it is DraftKings I
only bet with DraftKings and I only use
happy hippo Kratom because it only
Kratom I actually will only use I use
their concentrated shots before I did
this show this is the sour apple I like
the butterscotch right now
butterscotch-ish right right they're
trying their best sour apple is pretty
tasty the I think it's blue raspberry
ones fantastic but if you want Kratom
that can actually trust what's in the
actual bottle and however you want to
get it I use the contrary shots but they
have gummies they have powders they got
it all man listen if you got a busy
schedule you need to get stuff done you
need to get focused you need to be the
optimal version of yourself like Kratom
help you get there all right all right
you get nice and warm it's balanced you
get a good mood feeling it's fantastic
my favorites like I told you this is the
sour apple concentrated shot I like the
butterscotch as well try whatever you
want however you want to get your Kratom
do it with happy hippo their Kratom is a
Hidden Gem it's my Limitless pill go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick 23
thick with 3cs
t-h-i-c-c-c-2-3 promo code is thick23
use that as many times you want share it
with your friends your aunt your uncle
your Myspace friends whoever you want to
use it use it thick 23 20 off
happyhippo.com best crater on the planet
let's get back to the program
um
yeah so this is MMA fighting they know
fighting
um round one 10-9 Fury agree round two
ten nine Paul
okay let's give him that one I disagree
but let's give him that one round three
ten nine Paul
interesting round four 10-9 Fury round
uh six ten eight Fury
um round nine
notice so it's uh round six is nine nine
overall fifty Seven fifty five Fury then
round seven is ten nine Fury overall 67
64 Fury
in round eight
oh Paul yeah you can see that
and then and then the official decision
was 74 75 76 73 7673 yeah I agree 76 73
is fine
um let's see a few times how hard it was
dealing with all the injuries adversity
um I thought it was cute he dedicated to
his daughter the more the more I sit
with Bambi I'm liking it the more I sit
this little this little British Bambi
with her daddy's blue eyes that's gonna
be a cute [__] kid and their mom's a
dime piece shot to their men I I have
actually so much more respect for Tommy
Fury remember I was introducing I'm sure
a lot of the way the fan base was
introduced to Jake Paul like the first
time you you're introduced so and that's
how you know them so for Tommy Fury
that's a guy from love Island that's the
handsome Bastard with shoulders for days
and that freaking bronze skin that just
won't quit Daddy and the blue eyes with
the dime piece girl that's how I know
you know that's just that's how I was
first introduced him and they said he
boxed I was like I looked him I was like
at the time he was like three and I'm
like yeah okay that's not a real box
that's just a fine ass dude with a big
old wiener right and then and then with
Jake Paul a lot of people I would assume
like that's the YouTuber that's the
Disney kid you know so that's why people
can't get over it like oh he has a bear
noise tattoos now we're supposed to take
him serious so that's where you know
people they have those narratives and
they just can't fathom oh my God people
change and want to do different things I
think he's gonna stay at Disney you
can't have a beard at Disney dude that's
come on Casey can't work there he got
fired he's a beard so I could work the
other bike out your beard [__] you work
here dude
um so Tyson what he says uh or uh Tommy
says I had a vision I would win this
fight no one believed me uh he says that
the diarrhea championship belt he has
over his shoulder was like trying for a
world title that's how you say it I
don't know it is I'm telling you ask
about Paul's rematch Cloud street says
he's open to it that's what Paul wants
here's my thing with that so I do think
Tommy won the fight
what else are they gonna do like if you
think about the trajectory of their
careers it's like remember that although
their Fame outweighs their talent and
their demand
you know if you're Tommy he at the end
of the day he only has eight fights then
he did win a decision over Jake Paul
who's been fighting for three years so
he goes he goes I think I approved I'm I
deserve to be a main event I can hang in
the main event spot now I can deal with
the pressure it's like sure sure but
you're not you're not gonna go fight the
big boys like that's not in his future
he's years and years and years away from
that and honestly I think with his Fame
and family it's probably not his path
um so I think these two need each other
a rematch exactly what they should do
and then if Jake were to win then you
get a Trilogy I think it would sell
pretty decently too I think I think both
whether you're Jake Paul fan or Tommy
Fury fan you both walked away like I
like both of them like that's how I
walked and I I didn't dislike Tommy I
didn't think his boxing was as good as
he showed on uh Sunday uh morning at 11
A.M here in California but
he surprised me man he looked good great
game plan the uppercut was there all day
um
you know so I think these two need each
other because when you look at the
landscape it's actually in boxing don't
forget it this is don't they're in the
Box in Lane but they're they're in the
fast lane while boxing's here like you
know at Ryan Garcia and he's fighting
Javonte tank Davis like that's a high
level that's real [__] boxing man I'm
not saying they're not boxers and
they're not they shouldn't get respect
but they're not on the same path as a
Ryan Garcia tank Davis Earl Spence you
know uh Terence Crawford Canelo Tyson
Fury you know usig like it's just
different right but there's clearly a
lane there but they need each other
um but mixed into that fast lane that
they're in you I could see you know a
Nate Diaz Tommy Fury would be cool
um Logan Paul's out there if he wants to
you know kind of
be the big brother redeem himself you
know and redeem the family I could see
that narrative working I could see a
rematch with Jake and if Jake were to
lose that one then Logan comes in and
they have that narrative and here's the
thing everybody's making money Tommy's
making all the money supporting his
family because they they do have to be
careful and
um I'm kind of a victim of it too as
fast as Jake was improving right I think
we finally saw the reality of where he's
at even though he says he has injuries
felt sick sure I think we saw the
reality is that he only does have seven
fights so this narrative that you know
he did beat Anderson Anderson's older
and he looked phenol that night you know
if Jake now how now how would you pick
Jake versus Nate after seeing that chin
I would probably pick Nate yeah that
performance he did look a little off
though he did he looked tired in the
first round he his mental didn't seem
there he didn't look on at any point the
right hand was very loopy there was no
faints his biggest reason why he won
that uh Anderson fight was his faint and
the dirty box inside this he was
grabbing a lot it you know it just it
looked like he had seven fights where
when he only had six fights he looked
like he had 20 fights so it's it's tough
to bet on these things it was tough to
predict these things
um you know so I think for for Jake you
know the nape fight is still there I
think Nate would give him a world of
trouble now
um the counter fight moved down the road
I think those things are still there for
these guys
um I you know I don't think it's gonna
hurt his next fight if he were to fight
a Tommy or Nate you know I think a lot
of people are gonna tune in to see him
lose now that he's lost and maybe
there's a little pressure off him too
where you know he felt like he had to
keep winning I think he's gonna realize
that all right you lost the decision in
maybe you thought you won whatever
um
you'll be okay man it's the fight game
people take losses you'll be okay if he
wants to now now to me we'll see you
know JQ has all the money in the world
makes all the money in the world off
YouTube and his Instagram and his
Network where he has like a sports
network down his own TV show and his
merch kids crushing him now we see how
bad he wants to be a boxer trust me
fighting is the best sport in the world
when you're knocking dudes out you're
undefeated everyone's like yo you're the
best man this is for it's the best sport
in the world when you lose it's the
worst at least you didn't get knocked
out because that's a different type of
loss but you're losing this and
obviously he's getting a ton of [__]
online
now we're going to see how bad Jake
wants it now your career actually begins
because when you're not gonna do that
and winning sure anybody can do that but
a real fighter gets knocked down and
it's how you like you said to find me
off my losses not my win so you know for
a guy to lose and and you're facing a
little adversity and maybe you know
you're thinking about your training camp
you're thinking about how how far you
have to go let's see what he does see if
he you know picks up his boots laces
them on and hits the road you know if
I'm handled I'm posting a video today me
training that's all I do I got that's
how bad I want it hopefully Tommy gives
me the rematch if not Nate what's up you
know another story of Logan's out there
but they're all in the same world Logan
Nate
Connor which is just a little bit of a
stretch he's under contract UFC but all
those guys are kind of under this same
umbrella in that fast lane boxing
entertainment Lane where they all need
each other
no hey Tommy don't get crazy and try
jumping out of the lane and fighting you
know a big name don't be cool Biko jump
in the lane make all the money right
where we all got under 10 fights it's a
10 Fight Club right 10 Fight Club 10
Fight Club millionaire club though stay
in that late don't get all froggy and
try to jump out of the lane be cool man
we all need each other you know so um it
was entertaining though the rest of the
card was whatever you know it's a bunch
of people you never heard of besides
Badu Jack
this problem with boxing it is what it
is it is what it is but um
this weekend you're you're gonna get a
fight you're gonna get a great card it's
worth every freaking dime and I don't
know what deals he's charging these days
but
um you know you have Jon Jones returning
right after a two-year layoff I think
it's almost three I think it's three so
yeah three year layoff and he's returned
to heavyweight now if it was anybody
else with a three year layoff fighting a
Cyril gone and his athletic ability and
he's been you know active and relevant I
would say what are they doing how are
you not going to give a guy a warm-up
well when you're considered the grace
while Time by most you know people and
also the president of the UFC calls him
the greatest of all time there's no
warm-ups I I would like to see him get a
warm up see how he did at heavyweight
you know see how he moves that heavy
weight see how his cardio is you know
like a tie to a Vaso have been fun for
him even a steepe would have been good
for him now I'm not saying those or even
a Derrick Lewis type of guy
those would bring great so many there's
so there's so many names where I think
they could toss them just so we could
see them out and then go for a title
shot the UFC's like nah man Francis is
out we need to figure this you know this
whole thing out who knows how many
fights you have left you're fighting out
of all the guys it's the worst matchup
possible for you no worst matchup
possible because
stylistically he's a better Striker Tech
you know technically with his kickboxing
background he's better Striker he's also
more athletic than John
that being said also stylistically he's
the weakest grapple in the top ten by
far like you look at his entire resume
especially his last
ah no
he hasn't fought one Grappler
the best Grappler that he's fought
doesn't mean saying this these are the
words coming out of my mouth the best
Grappler that he's fought is a man named
Francis in Ghana and Francis had one leg
and took him down multiple times and
controlled him
oh
what do you think John's gonna do to him
fam and listen I I'm a surrogon fan he's
amazing to watch if uh uh I do think if
John didn't go to heavyweight he'd be
your champ for quite some time until
um I think my boy uh from England comes
back aspinall oh Thomas yeah I think
Tom's gonna be your champ eventually
even if John's running there John needs
to be careful because depending how many
fights John has Tom's gonna come back
could get one fight and it's a title
shot he has authentic ability and the
grappling and the power to give John
some Fritz but he's take him out of the
equation right now the worst matchup
possible for him is zero gone
because his movement his athletic
ability he doesn't move like a
heavyweight and for your first fight at
heavyweight you're fighting a
heavyweight that moves like a
middleweight so if you are a betting man
that's what you would bet on that John
can't get him down he's too athletic
he's too strong John's not strong enough
at heavy weight then you're also banking
on
the version of John that we saw three
years ago where if you look at John's
resume you know he's beat the who's who
there's a reason why he's the best to
ever do it his level of difficulties by
far trumps anybody's resume in the pound
for poundless but if you are banking on
Cyril gone when this fight you're
looking at John's record all right
Dominic Reyes I thought he lost that
fight I don't you know there's kind of
I'll have a conversation with anybody
you know nobody got robbed but most of
the fan base think Dominic Rays won that
fight
Thiago Santos Split Decision some people
thought he lost that fight Nancy Anthony
Smith fight then you know Alexander
Augustine did work on the DC was uh
overturned uh by the California State
athletic commission he beat uh OSP that
was a rough fight for him
um then Daniel Cormier was a great one
Global Tech's here great one Alex
Alexander Gusman the first time uh UFC
165 sorry John I stole the Limelight on
that one because I choked out Matt
Montreal and everyone's talking about me
and not you but whatever
um and then you know Chelsea and Victor
Belfor Rashad Evans little Machida
Clinton Rampage Jackson Shogun Rua again
I stole the Limelight from John because
I knocked out crow cop that was UFC 128
John I apologize before that was Ryan
Bader then Vladimir matashenko Brandon
Vera beat the brakes off Matt Hamill
again stole the Limelight there because
I got knocked up by Roy Nelson so I'm
apologize it's just a reoccurring theme
right I keep stealing the Limelight from
the greatest ever do it and here we are
I'm talking he's fighting this weekend
so he still wins but it when you look at
John's resume uh it's the the you know
he's the Alabama Crimson Tide of
fighting he he's in the SEC all these
other guys are in the pac-12. so you
know if you're banking on zero gone
you're banking on the version of John
that showed up the last fight which in
2020 February 8th damn yeah it'd be over
three years by the time he jumps in
there so
John's only 35 at heavyweight that's not
old
um you gotta Bank on two if you're a
Cheryl gone fan that John is still in
that motive he's done enough he's the
greatest of all time he hasn't been
working that much and there's gonna be
some ring rust and Cheryl Gunn's
athletic abilities gonna light him up on
the feet and this will be a kickboxing
match
I am not in that line of thinking I
think John is going to take him down and
do his thing and get him in that
crucifix and elbow his French face like
Pate that's what I think is going to
happen whether it's in the first round
second round third round it's going to
happen fourth and fifth I don't think
Sarah God makes it that long so I'd say
John gets a finish under three I see
John either ramming his face in the Pate
in the first three or he gets them down
sir gun who's not a natural Grappler
gives John his back going to stand up
and John chokes him out with rear naked
choke but either way John gets done via
elbows TKO or submission real uh rare
naked choke that's how I see it go down
or standing like you did against Leo
Machida I think he gets you know against
the clinch I think zero gone even though
he likes to stay on the outside and use
his footwork and pick guys apart and
he's fine with winning decisions
cereal guns grapple like his grappling's
not good he is Muay Thai and his inside
work is good with his elbows he likes to
get close and use elbows
well Sarah gone is definitely good
probably the best that heavy weight in
that grappling distance and that
striking it close counter kind of
distance with elbows but John's the best
to ever do it inside and he's very very
strong I guarantee zero dawn has not
faced somebody as strong as Jon Jones
but he fought France and Gano I know I
think Jon Jones as far as overall
grappling using his strength angles Jon
Jones the strongest ever do it I think
he absolutely mops the floor So Gone
just how it is that's how this goes down
you know let's take another little break
here because man y'all ever ate like a
THC gummy you don't know what's in it or
you've ate like a an edible and you're
like man I am so high right now it's not
even fun this isn't what I want to do
here and you don't know whether who you
can trust we can do well my friends that
mood got you covered man whether you're
new to cannabis or an Old Pro like some
of those potheads out there there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem a little iffy a little
sketchy at best when you want to relax
iffy is the last you want to feel it's
the last thing you want to think before
you get a little buzz going mood puts an
end to all the guessing games it's 100
federally legal Delta eight and Delta 9
THC you can have shipped straight to
your door no doctors no waiting just
Affordable Legal THC it's good man you
need to unwind you got some anxiety or I
like to use it just to wind down the end
of night helps me fall asleep I don't
wake up up groggy or hungover none of
that stuff all right mood offers
federally legal forms of THC extracted
from hemp plants all of their products
are regularly third-party tested and
Drug Enforcement Agency registered Labs
sourced from small Family Farms grown
organically experts at mood have tested
and tailored different strengths for
specific moods what are you looking for
energized we gotcha creative we gotcha
Focus say less other moods euphoric
erotic sleepy what your boy likes chill
social whatever you're looking for they
have a whole Garment of products to get
you exactly where you need to get all
right however you like to take THC mood
has you covered great for both beginners
and the veterans out there great tasting
gummies which I prefer classic flour
convenient pre-rolls and so much more
ready for a good time without the
guesswork gotcha order your THC products
from mood today that's m-o-o-d today and
for 20 20 off your first order and free
gummies what's up free gummies go to
Hello mood that's h-e-l-l-o mood
m-o-o-d.com use promo code shop
and you get 20 off your order and free
gummies that's hellomood.com promo code
shop 20 for free gummies
before we get back to the program my
long and faithful the longest brand I've
ever been with because I stick by these
guys because what they say they deliver
I'm talking about on it and if you need
the best nootropic on the freaking
planet you can use Alpha Brain they've
sold over a million bottles you've
probably heard of it but have you heard
of Alpha Brain Black Label the highly
concentrated for the real go-getters out
there it's gonna light your ass up and
get your mind right at the same time if
you don't like pills say less they have
Alpha Brain instant just boom all right
putting eight ounces of cold water your
boy you're thinking like Elon Musk then
Alpha Brain Focus shot boom little shot
you're ready to go man next thing you
know your computer programmer can't
spell it's insane Alpha Brain and
they're so positive Alpha brain's gonna
work
don't need a return no return necessary
to give your money back keep the
off-brain give to your buddy who's more
appreciative how dare you it works they
got krill oil joint oil they got protein
powders creatine glutamine virotech
shroom Tech they got immune stuff for
you they got everything workout Gear
streaming Fitness you can save 10 off
Alpha Brain Black Alpha Brain instant
Alpha Brain shots regular Alpha Brain
can do all that just go to audit.com
you get temps off the entire freaking
site what else are you going to use on
it.com slash shop you save 10 off
everything on the site from training
gear to streaming Fitness to Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain Black kettlebells Primal
Bells on-demand workouts home fitness
programs club and steel maces Home
Fitness Essentials like hard Hydro Core
bags on it sandbags yoga mats they got
it all what are you doing on it.com 10
percent off everything I just told you
now let's get back to the program
but thomaswell is a different animal
he's he's on the sidelines right now
with his knee which just blew out but
freak accident uh with our boy there
Curtis blades so
um that's the real test for John but
yeah overall if you're a Jon Jones hater
you're baking on ring rust you're
banking on he does he did get hit at
light heavy weight a bunch of times
which you can't do at heavyweight
um and you're baking I'm not using his
wrestling because he really hasn't used
his wrestling at like heavyweight now
I'm under the assumption that John a
didn't get up for those fights those
guys did not excite him especially after
the resume of in the body of work that
he's done uh so he didn't train as hard
wasn't into the fight and there's a real
result of that you got those kind of
half half-assed fights now I could be
completely off and John after three
years you get ring rust he looked slow
and gets lit the [__] up like a
Christmas tree Maybe
but I'm willing to put my money where my
mouth is and take Jon Jones via
submission or TKO via elbows ground and
pound uh under three rounds
great [__] fight so I had to
reschedule the shows and do a fight
campaign for it I can't wait man John's
my favorite to watch love love the guy
now outside the ation inside that icon
he's the best to ever do it outside
might be the worst ever do it but inside
the best the only one worse would be War
Machine and that's a far cry for worst
yes try to kill a girl yeah
um and then the rest card's uh tasty
it's worth your money you got chefchenko
Alexa Grasso that one's interesting
because Chef Shanker a lot of people
thought she lost her last fight Grasso
is a Savage on the ground has good
boxing but I would predict shift change
who does get it done
um you have Neil and uh Chef cat right
Chef
[Music]
um uh is a Savage it's a tough fight for
Neil very tough fight for Neil but it's
also a big step up for uh shaft dog here
Chef cat it's a big I'm gonna call him
Chef cat it's a big step up for Chef cat
because he does have a win over my boy
uh Neil
um but that's just a it's a different
animal the this needle is a different
animal he's a lot more explosive a lot
more dangerous but shaft cat has world
champion written all over him uh Cat
Daddy has can get it done uh gamrat
Jalen Turner probably your fighter of
the night in all honesty I don't think
any of those other fights are gonna be
fine tonight get him right Jalen Turner
phenomenal fight definitely deserves uh
its spot on the main card and then the
Great White Hope uh one of my favorite
Fighters and uh man America is banking
on this cat Bow nickel no pressure Beau
uh Jamie Pickett is [__]
nothing against Jamie Pickett I don't
care who it is unless you're in the top
five Bo nickel is gonna absolutely
wrestle your dick off and submit you
that's how it goes the kid is the truth
and then your main event for the prelims
yeah Cody garbrandt yeah I'll take it
Derek Brunson uh du policies sign me up
I actually think Derek Brunson wins that
fight uh Julie Marquez great fighter
that's a fun one Ian Gary's fighting he
could be your fight of the night easily
yeah Jessica Pena on there but uh
whenever Ian Gary's fighting that's
always I can't believe he's not least in
the ESPN prelims
on ESPN plus he's on the UFC Fight Pass
ESPN plus prelims but Ian Gary's a
Savage Savage
yeah but uh it's a great card overall I
have Jon Jones via TKO or submission
like I said under three I've shift jenko
I'll take uh shav Cat Cat Daddy I'll
take gamrat and then bow nickel via
however the [__] he wants how about that
suck my dick
what else you got chin I have a question
for you what dude
uh so this is a lot I can't remember I'm
fired up for this card dude bro we were
just talking in case talking earlier in
case they hit a boner for it you guys
jacked off well he didn't jack off but
he has a bone hell yeah dude I get it
I get it yeah dude we're super slow do
it right now no thanks dude feel an
extra froggy piss on the sink
that ain't happening or [__] it like
uh Howie like how he said how he went up
he was like I [__] it
that was such a fun show dude yeah so
much fun not a bad gig yeah Boys on a
Sunday anyone mad at work on a Sunday
fun yeah so much fun yeah uh so I
remember you said you trained with Jon
Jones and he would kind of like mess up
heavyweight fighters toy with us right
I'll tell you names off here but I mean
Brian Hall of Famers and me whatever you
want to place me in that category I mean
dude and he would be Shark Tank so it'd
be John cutting weight at light heavy
doing God knows what the night before
and we'd be like we're gonna [__] this
cat up we're all training like warming
up and he'd be like gloves and no and
like shin guards like all right let's go
and they're like John you're staying in
there for five rounds you guys are fresh
he's like yeah that's fine and one kid
was on clear cocaine was like a
Tasmanian devil doing spinning back fist
non- destroyed him destroyed me
destroyed the other guy who was a world
title [__] Contender destroyed a guy
who's a former world champion like
mopped the floor with us no issues zero
everyone's like I don't know what to do
I was like I don't either I don't know
what the [__] to do the best I've ever
seen
hands down I've been around everybody
never seen somebody like John
never yeah so the question is like a lot
of people are saying is that extra
weight gain does that take away from
that stuff that he was able to do with
you guys yeah you know he's going to
take away from his creativity you know
and also
you know here's the longest reach he's
tied for the longest reach ever in the
UFC with Stefan
I know you have to make him fly coach on
Spirit Airlines that's how [__] up it
is but like across Seas like yo you live
in [__] Amsterdam once you fly to
Vegas on Spirit Airlines in coach all
the way in the back he said can I just
have at least the plus room though shut
your tall mouth giraffe get on the
goddamn plane and he would that's why he
retired his knees were killing him
flying
that's I mean breaking news
um yeah that's that's what you got to
wonder you know is is put on that extra
weight gonna slow him down because also
with that reach he was able to get away
with a lot
but if you notice John in his prime
against gustafin uh well the second
guess when he absolutely mopped the
floor with him but the one that he to be
fair he barely trained her first guest
fan but anytime he fought of a guy of
same stature and height he struggled he
struggled you know Anthony Smith taller
uh Thiago Santos taller Dominic Reyes
taller the notes he struggled with those
guys uh now he didn't mark Gus Finn in
the rematch uh DC Merc and that's a no
contest which now this what's crazy and
this I think that uh Beau Hightower
tweeted this is that up there too it's
so interesting now going based off you
saw the rules John would that would not
be overturned so it kind of validates
John now you can't say you can't do that
right because then what about Nate Diaz
Nick Diaz and you know the weed stuff
and all that or certain guys that got
busted but now it's fine you can't go
back and no because at that time yeah it
was illegal at those at that exact time
it was illegal so the the no contact's
Gonna Stand but it does give those like
me that argue that John's the greatest
of all time people go yeah but PDS yeah
but now he would be in the right
I'm always going to disagree with that
girl because he's still got Pops for
stuff that should not be in his system
so he did something you know
did he yeah dude prove it
picograms yeah yeah I mean but yeah he's
definitely yeah we watch fights forever
you know since his body at work yeah
probably the best fighter ever but I
mean that's I would love to hear it I'm
the argument would be the only religion
khabib doesn't work can do a long enough
rain John has more title defenses I like
heavyweight legit against the best of
the best he has more title defenses than
sir gone has fights
so I think John's experience is really
going to show here also saragon's never
fought a Grappler
ever not only is he just fighting a
Grappler he's fighting the best to ever
do it the smartest to ever do it if you
think Sarah gone can last 25 minutes
with that I get some beachfront property
selling Nebraska you feel me
you biting chin I'm not
yeah I mean but remember we talked about
this before I think the whole let's say
you know we know Jon Jones skill set his
talent it's like unmatched right he's
he's amazing but I think if you did take
stuff it's something with your mental
like you're going to be so much more
confident you'll be able to do more
things for sure so if he did that stuff
and that was the you know put them over
the edge to make him so great if he
doesn't have it like even though he's
super talented if your mental's not
there like yeah yes I don't know yeah
there's there's some you know questions
going into this fight but I will still
put my money in those questions I think
now he's just like yeah he's a Savage
Savage his mental game is second to none
he trained like four days before he just
put Brian Bader Bader in the baby cradle
and submitted them you're like Jesus
Christ dude what's wrong with this guy
yeah I remember watching them back in
the old days he was so like unique all
of his different like everything is true
touched the fake the takedown backspin
and elbow kicks oblique she's one that
started the the kick to the knee like
you know Savage yep started with open
finger poking the eye right he does
Pokemon yeah who knows if it's
accidental but yeah what else you got
dude okay so yeah there's a few nights
yeah Brendan Allen he's ready for a big
test he submitted Andre Munoz which is
insane Andre's a savant one comes to the
ground and Brendan Allen looked
phenomenal same spelling as your name
too yes
hell yeah Tatiana Tatiana's words look
phenomenal listen same thing they didn't
give her any warm-ups Montana De la Rosa
is no punk she bullied her and it's at
FlyAway you know she she uh lower class
than that weight class wise so she went
up and wait she comes down her next
fight I'm sure she's gonna come down
should be a real problem she can be your
champ as long as she stays injury free
with the neck and the knee if she can
figure that out she's your champ
guarantee it there's nobody else I'd bet
on more than Tatiana's words yeah but
that's all predicate on her neck and me
she looked great though so I think yeah
then our boy uh Jordan hello love it you
know he's married with kids I didn't
know that
I did he had great post fight interviews
we have it here yeah yeah go ahead yeah
but no so that was one with where that
guy Adam mentality world who follows all
the shows he's going to ask the question
if this and that we how much sugar is in
his tank or if I forgot what the actual
what it was it was super funny we
laughed so I didn't realize this but I
guess Jordan 11's been bullied his
entire life because he's like so
different yeah so it's just different
here's the thing just because you're
flying boring doesn't mean you're a gay
man
he's a badass yeah badass
it doesn't speed up I know do the way he
dresses I'm a like a big fan of a fan
fruity you know being the first openly
gay UFC fighter
entire life and being bullied off a whim
does not hurt at all you know it's easy
to talk crap when you're looking up at
somebody you know so take a bully me all
they want until I lose the next one and
they better stop because that's not nice
and Free Speech shouldn't be legal you
know I've been bullied I'm so happy I'm
in a great mood I look good I feel good
I performed good got hit a little bit
more than I should have but that's his
grandpa soup by the way who passed away
my last fight isn't me getting tea
bagged in front of a bunch of drunk
degenerates
so I'm pretty good pretty damn good I
hate losing I'm so glad that the last
fight in my mind is going to be this
it's going to be a dominant win an
impressive showing for me if I do say so
myself not to be cocky but I'm very
happy I'm very impressed with myself I
have a lot of emotions yeah yeah he's a
flamboyant you know what he is he's a
smart guy that's who he is he's like
that nerdy like Big Bang Theory
uh with some little little sugar in this
thing
sugar not me likes wieners sugar meaning
he's flamboyant uh fashionable badass
fighter yeah he's great he's such an
entertaining person I don't know why
you'd bully that guy I mean I mean he
can also beat anybody exactly uh also
during the weekend
um one Championship had the rematch I
know John vinegar Fabricio Andrade got
it done dude he's done lineker he looked
didn't work against John yeah and then
uh Daniel Kelly looked phenomenal too
she's a little beast super beast
and your boy Todd Duffy I don't know if
you knew this I knew he was fighting but
he lost right so he beat Philip defreeze
before but yeah jacked him up here in
this fight and Todd grew his hair out
looked cool let's just you know just
didn't get it done it's a bummer I love
Todd
alrighty
um this is just a little
a little Scoop from remember how like
Francis ingano apparently said it wasn't
about the money when his con you know he
was doing the negotiations for his
contract I guess Ali Abdel Aziz kind of
let it let it be known that he wanted 30
million four fights in the OC and that
was one of the things just he's like no
yeah a number of alleged leaked messages
sent by MMA manager Ali hold on and was
Ali negotiating for him from his boxing
element
so I reveal that I never seeking to make
over so it sounds like no he didn't want
30 million from the UFC that's what I
thought at first he was saying he's
gonna make over 30 million for his
boxing debut last month anyway confirmed
that UFC Nagano had failed to reach an
agreement
and it was also going to make him the
highest paid heavy weight in my history
uh but they're failure to agree on
co-promotive boxing for uh Francis led
to the talks breaking down
interesting
um
what's inside so I'll say right now
what's next with him is Deontay Wilder
yeah you don't have a fight coming up he
wants to do the fight Tyson Fury has
usig that is no joke
's Ukrainian he's fighting for Ukraine
obviously under a lot of pressure
[__] USIC is a monster that's what
tongue Fury I'm sorry Tyson Fury needs
to focus on Deontay Wilder he's down
he's a free agent too they're they I
I've heard on the the Grapevine they've
already started talking about contracts
and stuff so that's more realistic than
anything
the Tyson Fury is a still distant kind
of thing I do think it happens
eventually depending how Deontay Wilder
Now France goes in and gets Molly walked
by Deontay Tyson like gonna fight him
for what you know so I think for France
if we can make that big [__] you 30
million dollar paid off Deontay Wilder
it's also his best chance to not only
look good but get a win because
Deontay Wilder fundamentally is Tyson
for Anthony Joshua
Francis might have better technique as
far as a straight boxing Deontay Waters
boxing even uh Brian Garcia was talking
about like his foot's off the ground the
technique's not right but boy does he
hit hard power for Francis sign me up a
50 50 fight a 50 50 fight against
Deontay Wilder Francis Deontay 50 50 are
great odds for Francis because France
probably
98 2 against Tyson
95 five percent against Anthony Joshua
odds of winning not good
take the Deontay Wilder fight because
you can win that one you beat Deonte you
knocked deante out the world's gonna go
[__] nuts and you make a gillion
dollars then the Tyson Fury fights right
there [__] MMA what are we doing so it
wouldn't be the Deontay doing the MMA
and the box it would just be straight
everybody it'd be straight box then
we're watching boxes I hate when they're
trying to mix the rules stop
I think that was like deontay's request
yeah I know but that was weird yeah
okay so we talked about this last week
huh there's rumors about Conor McGregor
like kicking people off of tough that
actually were on the show that deserved
to be there but kicked them off to
replace them with his own guys I heard
Dana or Connor took care of the guys he
got kicked off so that's what Dana
White's saying here because someone in
the uh the press conference asked him
like is it true he's like who gives a
[__] he's like he's like he's coming
from you know from Dublin like it's hard
to get him here so he can do what he
wants to do and then we'll take care of
the guys yeah so he said you're trying
to get guys commit to coach to do the
coaching commitment especially when you
live in Ireland you know what I mean
yeah kind of going to get some things
that he wants nobody lost an opportunity
here if if there were guys that were
booked to do that we'll do something
with them it's not just like hey see you
later pal good luck to you you know have
a good life we'll figure it out we'll
take care of these guys so they get UFC
contracts and that's the only reason
you'd go on the show yeah now you're not
gonna have the same bump off of Conor
McGregor Michael Chandler run
I mean since you actually did the show
if that happened to you how and you had
a contrast yeah you'd be like I'd be
furious yeah especially at that time the
show was big and you know if you did
well you get an audience these guys are
banking on that but if he puts you on
like the contender series download
Contender series fair enough better than
a kick in the nuts and sent home yeah if
you're sent home that would just be
terrible
all right so we were oh wait I kind of
covered that already
let me see what he put so this is what
he put here
so this is from uh at Bow high tower DN
Jon Jones should get reparations for his
you saw the suspension given the signs
changed and now tests under 100
picograms per milliliters are not
positive anymore which is what genre
busted for uh none of his positive tests
would be a positive under the current
rules there's no contest against DC
should be restored to win the problem is
is at that time it was illegal yeah and
by the way he referenced an article that
was like in 2019 so then she just
randomly put this out and he's homies
with Jon Jones as well like he's part of
the whole Jackson wink yeah but he's
right yeah yeah that's true if it was
right if it was now so then Jon Jones
reply he retweeted it and then he
replied with this I feel officially
cleared there will be no asterisk next
to any of my performances it's good the
rest of the world can see what I've
known this whole time my only advantage
over my competition has been pure hard
work chin and he put chin on there I
know because you're a hater I'm not a
hater a little bad just being real man
I think he's part of the game so it's
like even those picograms and the guys
look at the list of guys I know that's
positive it's like that that was a game
that's why that's that's the weird thing
yeah yeah
all right uh moving on how do you think
everybody's clean now no I think people
have hey Jay let me ask something yeah
you ever seen a french guy is rip the
syrup dog
I'm just saying we're not you're not
saying that he's doing it oh
some questions yeah you're seeing a
french guy with a Godsmack tattoo in the
middle of their Jazz who's like gigantic
heavy but yeah yeah
hard work man hard work hard work
dedication uh so we talked about the UFC
fight that just happened and Brendan
Allen being one right now and it worked
out for him shining star raised his
profile also the that card if Brandon
Allen didn't give that finish that card
was awful yeah I was just watching like
Jesus Christ
I actually took a break watched the
movie The Whale then came back and
finished the fight that's how bored I
was
uh so anyways Ryan span I guess carlov
had to uh he got sick yeah he so he
wasn't able to fight so then Ryan span
this is him talking about his emotions
after that I think John Morgan asked him
a question oh what a nightmare for a
fighter he got the whole Camp the day of
and he's he's not even like worried
about himself he was he was more
concerned about his coaches putting in
all that work you know so I'll just play
a little bit of it what's the worst
feeling right now well honestly I
wouldn't call it a wasted Camp because
we weren't training for this yeah you
grow and get better and uh
the plan was to go back to work Monday
either way
[Music]
so I guess that's what we're gonna have
to do so it isn't wasted the
disappointment comes
from
me not getting the show off some of the
[__] that we've been doing they my team
I think it's emotional here poor guy
um
they invested a lot of time in me and uh
yeah it's tough I get it yeah so he was
more concerned about his coaches but
they're going to reschedule like soon
too that's what Dana said they're just
going to reschedule that I don't know if
it's gonna be a main event but still at
least they'll do it
what's this oh this was like a
yeah so this guy he got a point taken
away from him for biting someone's
finger yeah but he said there's no bite
the guy actually I forgot the freaking
oh versus Rafael Alves so I guess the
guy the guy put his finger in his mouth
and did this and he cut his own finger
but this guy was trying to spit his
finger so either way it's illegal like
either way there's two wrongs don't make
sure right but you can't hey you can't
fish hook yeah B you put anything in my
mouth I'm like Andrew friend from
Charlotte check my jaw's gonna clinched
down Daddy yeah
but he got a point taken away but
luckily he won he won the fight oh he
gives a [__] then as long as you won if
he would have lost because of that yeah
for sure
um oh this is Patty pimlet he mentioned
how he was really bothered by the fact
that Joe Rogan said that he didn't win
that fight against Jared Gordon and then
he even said that he when he watched the
fight back like immediately he thought
he won for like no problem most people
most guys do yeah but when he watches
back he's like yeah I didn't really win
this round or that round but he still
you know he it means that much to her he
wants a rematch with Jared Gordon I
doubt they do it but let's see he says
I've watched the fight back and I don't
think it was a dominant as I thought it
was straight after if everyone wants to
see it again I don't mind beating him at
the end of the year hopefully he beats
Bobby green tough fight for him
um then if he wants to fight toward the
back end of the year I'm game
I don't know if the UFC does it yeah I
don't know how big that fight is but
yeah definitely didn't dominate like you
thought he dominated yeah Barstool being
like give him the bonus everyone's like
well hey we're just glad he got the
[__] up decisions most people and then
when Rogan's like he lost that fight
game set match
Rogan's you know followers or whatever
he says he's he's their lord and savior
if he says anything at all yeah and so
it's gay when Rogan says you lost dude
you you'd much rather have the judges
give you a loss and Rogan say you win
that's how powerful he is
yeah
all right let's go
here Nate Diaz called out Logan Paul
because Logan Paul I guess during the
middle of the fight with Tyson or not
Tyson Tommy Fury yeah he's like you're a
[__] [__] and you're getting tired
I'll play it real quick it's very short
nine seconds
[Applause]
a mic in front of his face the funniest
part about the whole interview you watch
the whole thing he goes you ask my
brother and I love you man and then the
report goes I love you he's like no no
not you dumbass we don't know your name
I love you too bro yeah I had that I had
it for tfat kids hey man
it was awkward and then Nate's like
right there's a there's a heel and then
there's the baby face and Nate is the
baby face when it comes to this because
Logan's brother represent a certain kind
of fan base right which is you know
gimmicky and entertainment and then Nate
is real as they get so this is on brand
because this guy needs his ass beat then
if even if you're not an a DS fan you're
like yeah yeah he does preach brother
and he says this guy needs his ass beat
and who let this spoiled little [__]
yell obnoxious [__] during the fight you
have to yell that during the fights like
Jesus Christ look at the guy's face in
the back
he's all damn dog
his hair's all [__] up that's freaking
funny I don't know if that's like
are they trying to plan something for
Nate and Logan I have no uh Nate but
Nate it's
it's a what Conor does what Dylan dance
does they keep like whenever there's a
big fight like they're gonna make sure
their name's in the pot oh it's
brilliant and it's so funny dude yeah
yeah he does his thing
uh this is a quick one Jon Jones named
his top five Fighters and tell me what
you think about this this is weird he
put himself as I think number one let us
tell you how good you are John you don't
tell us although if you ask Jordan he
won't I don't think he'll say it
publicly but yes Jordan he'll be like Oh
I'm the best of all time I'm close so
this is my my top fight I would say
myself Anson Silva GSP khabib and Jose
Aldo
and this is from mmannews.com
uh I mean I don't have a problem with
this list
I'm just like the question the question
I had was like name yourself now let us
tell you how great you are yeah don't
don't tell us how great you are that's a
Bruce Lee quote even though Bruce Lee
never fought still here's some good
knowledge
I heard there were some sort of fights
nope alrighty nope uh this is Jon Jones
tweeting about Francis ingano I found an
interview of friends that's talking
about Halo forever be that honest Beauty
champion because no one beat him once I
saw that my tone changed I thought I
would tell how I really felt he did make
the right decision he left before I came
back smart move yeah yeah I do think
John beats him
um but I think both guys went I think
for John to be zero gone and reina's
heavyweight champ is brilliant I think
for Francis to leave and get a Deontay
Wilder Tyson Fury fight is brilliant it
works out for both guys
uh uh this is John I don't think I
deserve any criticism I'm here I'm here
Francis had the opportunity to face me
and he opted out of the opportunity for
different reasons and fighting either
John
um if anyone should be criticized it's
Francis if I'm correct who's offered the
biggest contract in heavyweight history
for UFC not biggest contract that he can
make more money banking on himself yes
um he trust me if he's not paying for 30
mil
he should get that hopefully he gets
that uh he didn't believe in himself
friends didn't believe in himself he
wasn't willing to gamble himself
that doesn't work for me Francis left to
bank on himself to gamble himself I I
don't think France is scared of Jon
Jones I just think he's like I honestly
don't think gives a [__] I think he's
like nah man I want to make life
changing money over here the UFC I can
make great money but I'm gonna have to
fight John Stipe aspinall it's a tough
[__] road and I can make great money
but not [__] you money if I just get one
of these big fish Deontay Wilder Anthony
Joshua Tyson Fury to jump on board I
don't have to do [__] and then I could
do that if he wants to play hardball not
co-promote I can do that and then jump
back on over it like how much bigger of
a fight between Jon Jones and France
would it be if Francis goes out there
knocks Deontay Wilder the [__] out
[__] UFC what's up now hey it's paid
what he thinks he deserves not 30 mil
not even close but he will make great a
lot more money and also that Mac do the
fight so if John goes out there Molly
wops Cyril gone France it goes out you
know mid middle this year late uh fourth
quarter I'm sorry early fourth quarter
this year knocks out Deontay Wilder and
then they renegotiate a contract and
then you get the fight for official
baddest man on the planet because then
it's like maybe Francis is the badass
man on the planet he just knocked out do
you have to water in boxing and John
just beat Sarah gone that fight dude
biggest of all time yeah
there you have it there you have it
uh we talked we talked about this on
fire companion but so you know there's a
there's apparently a script for the Jake
Paul team that hey doesn't work they
start to tell lies and in the script is
like a whole thing with whatever I saw
that [__] at the end of the script
basically Jake Paul wins so there's a
pretty obvious reason like people should
not believe in this stupid conspiracy no
he's got like two and Mike Perry post I
got like two million views it's so
stupid you know people are just sheeps
but they just hate like they hate that
Jake's doing this and stepping outside
the box and he's risking his you know
his his you know his career he's risking
his everything people hate that triggers
people so like this has to be fake you
know
yeah anyways this is proven wrong
obviously
um oh this is okay speaking of fake I
saw this interview with Rampage
and this is on hold on
Chris Van Vliet his channel
I'll play real quick
I know that in UFC no never mind
he's talking about Pride yeah make money
on the money this is entertainment
probably was all about entertainment a
lot of those Japanese Fighters they were
pro wrestling yeah yeah so some of those
fights was fake right and I've seen I've
seen people uh I've seen them hit each
other for real but it's a fake fight
I've seen it and Fighters like we we're
a different breed like people don't
understand this save me and you man you
fight and you tell and you say listen
Rampage I'm getting 10 million to take a
dime you gotta look good though I gotta
really hit you I get hit all the time
okay and then you know that you're gonna
hit me I know that you're going to hit
me but you know you're gonna knock me
the [__] out dude I'm thinking I'm just
gonna get hit then I gotta fall down
boxes do this all the time I know that
there's been
they put that clip of Jake Paul and
Tyron Woodley which just straight up I
don't know what all they're doing there
but um yeah so I'm Atomic bombed to the
face
we've heard from before like Pride FC
does a lot of shady stuff right back in
the day yeah 100 you have UFC is not
faking anything why would they risk it
yeah that's so stupid
uh we kind of knew this already but
hanzat's coach says he's gonna then his
next fight's gonna be Whitaker
middleweight Whitaker give me Palms out
Whitaker that thing makes my dick so
Frosty if it's harms out Whitaker
oh my God have you seen how Whitaker
shrimp on the barbie dude and by Barbie
I mean this giant dick hamzat Whitaker
is the [__] fight of the ages
I'm not so [__] scary he is and then
even Whitaker was like just when they
asked him about the fight you can even
see in his eyes
I mean yeah I'll take it yeah yeah he's
so huge he's a crazy Pig yeah ain't
Nobody Wanna I think
the hot take I think harms that's the
scariest fight I ever compete in the UFC
hands down
why can't I get a fight yeah why can't I
get a name on the last guy in two weight
divisions who can't book a fight
name one
like straight up can't book a fight
where under the radar which I know for a
fact is happening they're like
unheard I've never heard of that
happening ever
ever I know guys where they want a title
shot now from a contender like no no
give me the title shot not because
they're scared because they just want
the title shot I've never heard of
anybody
in top five turning down another man
ever
it's insane yeah check out the balls on
Gilbert I know he went from big [__]
acai balls
ain't nobody want that you don't want
them problems
they were on his last fight they had to
switch the guy on a day's notice to take
the Kevin Hall and so much of a badass
Kevin Hollins
yeah I think the only guy that I
remember being scary but not because he
was in a later no no uh who's smart
Polaris because he would not stop
that's the only person I could think he
fought Nate Mark Hart My Boy Nate the
Great and freaking Alan Belcher Nate
once you know he not gay Mark hard okay
[Laughter]
yeah that was tough
uh so Danny White in this article
Animania Dana White's open to Islam
marketer versus Alexander volkanovsky
the rematch but they both have to win
their next fights yeah yeah so and he
he wants he says yair has to get the
opportunity yeah so once the higher wins
or sorry once Yara fights and whoever
the winner is then ain't nobody being
broken off get that weight class not
happening
yeah I'm not happy
he's a badass for sure uh so Curtis
blades here boy Curtis he's been asking
he's doing the damn thing he wanted
Sergey pavlovich who's this one of the
scariest guys in heavyweight the Russian
cat just [__] everybody up and he's
got him for April 22nd yeah they're
headlining yep headline UFC Fight Night
April 22nd yep oh that same night as uh
our boy Ryan Garcia oh [__] yeah but I'm
sure the times
yeah yeah Ryan will fight probably after
they fight yeah UFC's good about that
yeah
um quick one here so
the whole algeman Sterling versus Henry
suhuto algeman confirmed that they're
gonna fight
I think you've confirmed on this date
hold on
yeah May 6th it's not they're not signed
yet whatever but uh algae being
confirmed so most likely it's going to
happen in him and Henry sudo and then
Sean O'Malley is obviously who they want
for the backup but Sean O'Malley says
like he's gonna turn it down because I'm
gonna just he's Rich As [__] and also he
doesn't want to go through all that crap
just to make sure you know just cutting
all that way it's on brand for sugar
right like everyone knows the kid's
making money but take it from your boy I
used to joke around all the time I'm
rich as [__] people don't like that
he was joking right I'm joking around
yeah I know but then eventually becomes
this thing yeah people should just
realize you're a comedian yeah hold on
no no no no no no no free passes here
yeah whatever uh he goes this leads me
in a little position you know uh do I
want to be a backup fighter I could be
technically if I want to be for this
amount of money do I need that amount of
money not really
I'm Rich As [__] weird flax no I'm
kidding but it's just like weight cuts
are hard dude they're very I mean I'm
almost thinking right now we're so far
out it's still tricky to say I might
just do a full fight Camp pretty much
Spar diet get to fight week and then
decide well then you would do it right
if he I'm sure if he feels like he's
good then those weight cuts that was for
him it is so light and it it [__] with
your body so is it worth it I don't know
what they're offering money-wise but the
chance to be fine to also is not good
yeah but man is that opportunity because
algebrae's been you know on and off with
his injuries Henry Sue has been on a
while yeah the probability of you
fighting is better than most fights
uh this reminds me so I remember you
tried to cut to light heavyweight at one
point right I get a 222. 222 so do you
remember how your strength was and and
your cardio my cardio is [__] sick
with it I always had a good Carter then
I cut weight I just I just trained
non-stop non-stop wow wasn't that tough
for me
at all but those guys are different like
I'm also coming from a heavyweight down
to 205 for Sean he's thin already so
he's kind of he's getting into like the
straight nutrients I could use a little
weight gut right I was thinking more of
the whole Jon Jones going up and going
down that's why I asked you with that
question that's other thing some guys
just look better because they're not
depleting their body of nutrients and
stuff so John could look but technically
better but we've seen guys like you know
Luke rockhold goes up and they look
really slow I don't think John's doing
especially he's done the right way he's
at time to do it it's not like this
random like you know years yeah it's
three years in the making so I think
you'll be all right do you remember your
strength though when you were down yeah
it felt good mom
that is cool uh this is a
about announcement Mackenzie Dern versus
Angela Hill love that fight yeah that's
May 13th underneath the win
and then also Edmond shabazzian versus
Anthony Hernandez and I I had to go look
back at their records so shabazzi won
his last one yep Hernandez won too right
Hernandez won three in a row yeah yeah
great fight yeah
yeah and then oh so remember hope
shabazzian figures it out he's such a
stud it seems like he is starting to
figure it out now uh so William Knight
remember the gigantic buff two dude yeah
crazy jacked um why do you like Tarzan
mine like Jane right for that fight for
that fight yeah for that one fight that
he had so apparently he's he's removed
from the roster so in this article
they're saying that he was cut but their
contracts were up anyways so there they
could potentially negotiate another
contract but for now he's not part of
the UFC anymore him and Jordan rights is
he ain't going to bodybuilding he's Jack
so jacked look at that ad on the right
healthy real hydration and someone's the
same business oh healthy and there's
just this
thick girl not like fun thick
that's insane that is insane and this
the pose is the same too G fit check out
this fat chick
okay I wasn't trying to rap though uh
this is Chris Curtis
uh getting upset he's gonna follow he's
a good follower
he's gonna fight gasoline but uh he was
upset that he was not on the main card
and he's talking he's basically talking
smack on Raul Rose's Jr who's the the
next big thing that's how it goes though
right so is Curtis the action man does
he deserve to be ahead of him 100
percent
in the kids 18 but
the UFC's it's the bottom line like more
people on TuneIn see this young kid
you'll see that one's sorry dude yeah
yeah
it sucks yeah the packing order is all
disaligned it's you know uh Twitter
followers and Tick Tock and Nintendo
gloves you know
but the thing that was kind of odd here
is like he calls Bounce from the main
card for such a child not it is a child
uh not gonna lie that bat order is
completely [__] one of the best cards
of the year and I get bounced from the
main card for a child I fought on short
notice have taken on whoever and gone
four and one to get ranked and I got
bounced for a kid with one fight yeah
I'm salty as [__] he should be
let me see the rest of the card
who else could they bounce you're not
going to bounce Holland you're not going
to bounce font
adrianos Jana is yes Champion written
all over him
yeah I I can see whether you see did it
I mean but also it's not a terrible
thing to be on the prelims
you look who else is on there Barnett
too man but our boy the thick boy
himself Beast Boy Barnett's on there
against Chase Sherman Michelle Waterson
ever heard of her Dime Piece fighter yet
uh Michael chiesa versus Lee the leech
and then you got Kelvin gaslin that's a
great preliment that's the best prelim
I've ever heard of yeah and he's main
Eventing that they have uh Merchant
calvillo's on there this card's exactly
that's the problem
why is that bottom one look like a bug
shot of Hughes see the very bottom right
that's a mug shot can we can we get a
[__] fighter profile it's a mug shot
oh my gosh that card is tasty daddy dog
that's better than you'll see 285
my God
definitely stacked my lordy Lord
Fontana is definitely fight of them I
can't wait for them that's a good fight
yeah shout out to Adrian yeah that's our
boy oh yeah this is a king of Velasquez
you know he's been I guess he's on I
don't know what it's called just some
sort of release yeah parole I guess bail
pose a bail so he's probably on parole
right so he's been training at AKA
teaching people there as well and then
uh he just posted this recently
he put I am back on social media and I
would like to thank everyone for your
words of inspiration thank you for
lifting my family and I through the
difficulties of life's darkest times boy
those times are dark purple dark these
difficult times will pass and will
forever influence us but nothing will
ever break our spirits
I love and appreciate you all forever
growth in a direction for the better
that was nice to see yeah thank God he's
at least on parole also the whole thing
with Islam and the IV stuff or whatever
so I guess this is from the fight Mafia
he was apparently the most tested
fighter in the UFC in 2022 oh wait hold
on updated
in 2023 I think it might be well I think
we're carrying over I think well 2023 so
the start of 2023 so the fight was in
February it's been tested eight times
the most UFC fighter here's the thing
back to that quote once the hate doesn't
work they tell lies so that IV right
these people were so upset that
volkanovski didn't win I thought he won
the fight but I don't know I'm not gonna
make [__] up I get how you can give it
to Mike Jeff not a big deal all good
well he's an IV that's not true unless
we have like actual proof then it's kind
of tough to say that even if it's true
under the rules he was allowed to no no
so in Australian commission remember
they're oh that's right yeah okay well
but who knows what happened there's no
definitive proof so you can't prove
someone wrong if you beat them in five
rounds everyone needs to get over it
I'm salty too what the [__] is this from
the same thing I just saw this I thought
that was funny so this is Lana Rhodes
you know she was dating that um I'm very
familiar with her dude what about her so
I don't know when this was taken but it
says she she goes taking applications
for my 2022 roster and then Dylan Dennis
I don't know how real this is I just saw
this on she put application so I thought
that was yeah she's kind of super batty
yeah
and I think this is the last one
I saw this so basically
hakasan nightclub in Las Vegas this is
going to be Jon Jones's after party
how crazy oh this is what is this the
plot of hate dude is this the script or
hangover for that I know dude this
thing's gonna be lady like a diddy
bro little booger sugar celebration
three or layoff some strap if he wins
some Bentleys dude that's the Vegas of
me [__] lit yeah I don't know why
this means he's gonna be like the Joker
hanging out the window
it's gonna be great yeah
hopefully everything's cool though yeah
that's pretty much all I have all right
kids well freaking enjoy UFC 285 this
weekend you've earned it man if you got
through that last fight card and you got
through some other [__] and the
pre-card for the Jake Paul uh Tommy Fury
fight you've earned this one fam so you
have UFC 285 which is stacked to the
freaking gills you have Jon Jones Cyril
gone chefchenko Alexa Grosso you have
Neil shaft cat the rat man you got gam
rot Jalen Turner Bo nickel Jamie Pickett
about to get annihilated you got Cody
garbrandt Derek Brunson duplicies Trevin
Jones Julian Marquez Ian Gary Jessica
Pena man this thing is stacked fam so
enjoy your fights come watch it with the
crew
special kaabass fight campaign Saturday
7 P.M Pacific live on thick boy YouTube
we have from busting with the Bros the
more handsome One his name's Will
Compton look him up he's the man you
also have jelly roll ever heard of him
number one song in country kind of a big
deal big man big heart big lover big
hugs you got Rampage Jackson MVP of
companion so far and myself let's go
down live 7 P.M Pacific thick boy
YouTube Brea is this Friday Bray improv
two shows almost sold out let's sell
these [__] out Brea Improv this
mother Trucking Friday your boy it's a
tour day it's not a shop and friends but
we'll have some special guests there
it's uh yep it's the oh he thick towards
coming to Brea California this Friday
and then next week Oklahoma city that is
March 9th through the 11th Bricktown
comedy club with my favorites uh
definitely won't go to the uh the bomb
site that bummed me out last time but
Oklahoma City Oklahoma is bricked out on
Comedy Club March 9th through the 11th
then I end March in Tacoma Washington
March 23rd through 25th tickets for my
Europe UK tour chin mayor may not be
there we're trying to figure it out but
it starts in Belfast Belfast June 15th
class cow June 17th Manchester June 18th
London June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd then
I end in my favorite place I've ever
done stand-up Dublin Ireland June 25th
one shown each freaking City it's a
theater tour baby get your tickets right
now London's almost sold out I think
tickets right now thickboy.com all right
enjoy the fights the fight campaign for
Tommy Fury Jake Paul is available right
now on Spotify iTunes Apple uh and
YouTube if you want to watch it that's
with the one and only Ryan Garcia who's
a huge fight coming up April 22nd
against Javonte tank Davis you have
Harry Mandel on there and also Adam Ray
it's a on one go watch it go listen to
it right now it's available for you guys
also my boy little brows and Austin just
dropped their new album it's their first
collab album ever together I think it's
called late to the party it's on Spotify
right now and iTunes it is purifier
you've heard me bump their music they
have that song uh Arizona they have a
bunch of other music on there these guys
are crushing it go get it right now to
be able on iTunes and Spotify it's
already over a million streams on
Spotify alone they're crushing it so go
download that if you need some new tunes
for this week love you guys thanks for
tuning in
that's it be nice to each other stay
safe love you guys till next time see
you Saturday at the fight campaign Live
on YouTube and then I also see you Brea
this Friday two shows I'm out